within just two years of launching this
platform became the world's largest
social media network eventually
surpassing over 100 million users and
within three years this website became
the most visited website in the us
surpassing even google and yahoo given
this explosive growth i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that this
platform was acquired for 580 million
dollars just two years after being
founded hearing this you might be
thinking that i'm describing the roaring
success of instagram
[Music]
but that was actually the story of
myspace and the part that we've yet to
discuss is its equally explosive
downfall in mid 2008 facebook would
surpass myspace in terms of user account
and within the next five years myspace's
user count would crumble from 115
million users to 36 million and the
worst part was that myspace would be
resold to another buyer for just 35
million dollars which is only six
percent of their initial 580 million
dollar buyout but that's not even
surprising given that virtually no one
uses myspace today
on the other hand instagram never became
the world's largest social media
platform
however its growth was just as explosive
as myspace within three years of
launching it instagram boasted an
astonishing of 100 million users and it
didn't take long for facebook to buy out
instagram for a whopping of 1 billion
dollars but as we saw with myspace rapid
adoption and doesn't necessarily
indicate long-term success and users can
dissipate faster than they came on this
isn't to say that instagram is going to
explode in spectacular fashion within
the next couple of years but at the same
time we're starting to see red flags pop
up that indicate that instagram may
share its final destination with myspace
so here's the top reasons that instagram
is doomed to become the next myspace
starting with the most concrete evidence
we have instagram's user base
while their overall user count is yet to
show any signs of slowing down something
that's worrisome is the demographics of
this user base and especially their age
if we take a look at instagram's age
demographics we'll see that only eight
percent of their user base is 13 to 17
year olds this means that the number of
high schoolers that are using instagram
is equivalent to the number of 45 to 54
year olds that are using instagram
this may not seem like a problem at
first glance but when we take a look at
their competitors demographics we'll see
just how much instagram is lacking take
snapchat for example
13 to 17 year olds make up just over 20
of their user base while 18 to 24 year
olds make up nearly 40
meanwhile 50 plus year olds make up just
3.7 percent which is 8 times less than
the 13 to 17 year old user base if we
take a look at tick tock we'll see a
demographic that's even more skewed
towards younger people tick tock's
largest user base is 10 to 19 year olds
who make up a quarter of their user base
something else to note is that even
though 10 to 19 year olds are the
largest demographic tech talk is quite
popular amongst other age groups as well
the reason this is a problem for
instagram is that it's concrete evidence
that they're not appealing to newer
generations like they used to this isn't
to say that teenagers aren't using
social media social media use amongst
teenagers is higher than ever before
in fact 97 percent of 13 to 17 year olds
use social media instagram is simply not
their top choice based on the
demographic numbers they far prefer
snapchat and tick tock meanwhile
instagram's demographic numbers are
starting to look more and more like
facebooks facebook is extremely
unpopular amongst 13 to 17 year olds in
fact there's more 55 to 64 year olds
that use facebook than 13 to 17 year
olds even the 65 plus demographic is
comparable to the 13 to 17 year olds and
facebook now there are some benefits
that come with an aging demographic
first of all your user base actually has
money to spend meaning that you can
charge advertisers a much higher amount
and secondly you probably won't have
stupid trends go viral on your platform
like dbs licks but that's pretty much
where the benefits end as people get
older they tend to spend less time on
social media not only because they have
more responsibilities but also because
they no longer feel the need to live for
the gram they tend to prioritize family
kids and close friends over keeping up
some sort of online persona while this
is probably good for them this is
terrible for social media platforms your
user base slowly evolves from teenagers
and young adults who spend three to four
hours per day on your platform to middle
age people who check in once every few
days or weeks i don't think i need to
explain why this is terrible for
business and unless instagram starts to
get newer generations on board this is
where they're eventually headed
aside from lackluster performance
amongst gen z instagram has devolved
into becoming copycats at first
instagram's parent company meta tried to
acquire their way to the top they spend
ludicrous amounts on acquisitions like
instagram and whatsapp but not every
business owner can be persuaded to sell
by just money for example facebook
offered 3 billion in cash to take over
snapchat way back in 2013 but snapchat's
ceo evan spiegel refused and when meta
realized that they couldn't acquire
every company they liked they just
started ripping off every company they
liked we saw instagram introduced
stories which were awfully similar to
snapchat stories we also saw instagram
launch wheels which were basically a
rip-off of tick tock now we can't give
instagram too much heat for this because
basically every social media platform
has resorted to doing this i mean just
take a look at youtube stories and
shorts
the problem with this however is that
such shameless copying leaves these
platforms with no originality as they
all basically become the same thing not
to mention it none of these copied
features are all that great at
attracting new users they may attract
new creators who are looking to leverage
the low competition but it rarely
attracts new users i mean if you don't
have tik-tok or instagram and you want
to watch short form videos why would you
download instagram over tik tok
especially when they're both free it
doesn't make any sense instagram's
demographic numbers prove this without a
shadow of doubt meta and youtube are
well aware of this as well and they're
not trying to attract new users with
such features per se
rather they're trying to preserve their
existing base and minimize losses in
watch time but as they spend so much
time on copying features and preserving
watch time they often forget about what
appealed to users in the first place
this is especially a problem with
instagram because the user base has
already started to turn on them and i'm
not talking about meta's privacy
concerns or political involvement i'm
talking about people who are turning on
instagram because the platform is toxic
to their mental health it's no secret
that instagram is filled with
over-the-top photos instagram has
transitioned from being a place where
you share your life with your friends to
being a place where you share your
highlights with people you know to being
a place where you share doctored photos
to impress strangers instagram users are
more aware of this than ever before
which has completely warped their
perception of the platform and i think
this is what meta should have focused on
they should have spent time encouraging
originality and authenticity which is
what attracted users to their platform
in the first place but instead they were
busy copying features from tiktok and
snapchat and as instagram slay morphs
into being just another social media
platform it'll just become even harder
for them to appeal to younger
generations
by this point it's no secret that one of
the main factors that's causing all
social media companies to squirm is tick
tock tick tock has taken the world by
storm and though many like to criticize
it tick tock was still the most visited
website in 2021 and given that people
only have 24 hours in a day all this
traffic has to come from somewhere and
more times than not that somewhere is
other social media platforms such as
instagram and youtube and looking
forward it doesn't seem like tick tock
dominance is going to stop anytime soon
over the years our attention spans have
only gotten smaller and smaller first
people switched from traditional media
like movies and tv shows to shorter from
online content like youtube videos and
now we're seeing them switch from
youtube videos to tick-tock shorts this
isn't to say that other forms of media
will be left behind completely but as
tick-tock continues as dominant it's
likely that other platforms will just
continue to bleed but honestly this
isn't anything new within the social
media space since the creation of social
media in the late 1990s users have
flogged from one platform to the next
first there was friendster then there
was myspace and after that we saw
facebook and twitter
at this point people switched from
computers to smartphones and we saw the
rise of instagram and whatsapp and then
we saw snapchat and now we have tick
tock
none of these platforms sit at the top
for more than a few years and they're
completely abandoned within a few
decades given that instagram was
launched in 2010 it's been nearly 12
years since the platform was launched so
it's not surprising that instagram is
approaching its peak form if it's not
already there something else to note is
that meta themselves have more or less
just accepted this fate 10 years ago
they were vigorously trying to acquire
the next big platform in order to always
stay on top but it seems like mark
zuckerberg has come to the realization
that this is simply unsustainable as a
result he's been shifting the company's
focus into vr and the metaverse he even
changed the company's name from facebook
to meta which is something you never
want to do for branding purposes
at this point mark is basically all in
on the metaverse and he's even been
telling shareholders to break for
significant losses due to the metaverse
over the next five years last year alone
meta spent ten billion dollars on the
metaverse and given mark stands i don't
think this will be changing anytime soon
so even if instagram isn't completely
consumed by new social media players it
looks like instagram will eventually be
left behind by meta themselves
in the end instagram is extremely
nostalgic to many of us because we grew
up with it we used it all throughout
middle school high school and college
and as young adults many of us still use
it on a regular basis so it might be
hard to imagine this massive platform
slowly withering away
but the thing to keep in mind is that
all popular social media platforms cross
the same stage myspace and friendster
were so nostalgic to a specific
generation as well but that didn't stop
these platforms from eventually going
down
15 years ago it probably seemed
impossible for something like myspace to
die yet here we are as instagram
continues to lose its originality and
meta shifts your focus on the new
projects it just becomes more and more
likely that newer generations abandon
instagram we're already starting to see
this amongst 13 to 17 year olds but this
will simply become even more blatant in
the next 10 to 15 years as these guys
grow up and soon enough people will be
talking about instagram like we talk
about myspace and friendster today but
that's just what i think do you think
instagram will break the trend and
survive for decades comment that down
below
also drop a like if instagram is
nostalgic for you and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
to subscribe and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you